a news station in new mexi new mexico
had a segment
with a quote local hr expert named
heather and they were talking about
pronouns and how important it is to use
pronouns in the workplace
let's watch some of that
pronouns in the workplace do you know
what your co-worker prefers well joining
me today is heather talamante founder of
tell us about yourself inc thanks so
much for joining us this morning
good to have you back so first off let's
talk about dei in the workplace and
that's better known as diversity equity
and inclusion how do we go about the
discussion of pronouns so essentially
the employee will reach out and say hey
this is my preferred pronoun this is how
i would like to be
addressed in the workplace how we go
about it is by respecting their request
right so you want to make sure when they
say this is what i would like to be
referred to
we address it and we we honor that and
we
moving forward use that term whether
it's he she
they them their whatever they would like
to use we want to make sure we honor
that request and make them feel
comfortable in the workplace is it
appropriate for someone to ask what
someone's preferred pronoun usages are
you probably wouldn't want to ask that
person would ask you okay so you know if
you um if they haven't fully made the
decision on what pronoun they would like
to use let them come around to that
decision and then ask
if they haven't asked yet it's not safe
to assume we don't want to make any
assumptions right so this is going to
have make people be more patient or have
to be patient you do you have to be
patient if you are the employee that is
asking for a new preferred pronoun or
pronoun that's not necessarily natural
for individuals yet
just be patient as they learned to use
the new pronoun or to address you by
that pronoun
yes be uh be patient with me that is
very important you know if i'm working
with you and you have a new pronoun you
want to use
uh that's the only thing i would ask is
is personally please be patient with me
um and in fact uh i would have to
bid that you be very patient indeed
because you'll be waiting forever
for me to respect your stupid pronouns
so you're going to be very very patient
you'll be gonna be waiting until you die
for me to care or respect your pronouns
because i never will
ever
it's not going to happen
well it's it's it's what makes them
comfortable you know it makes them
comfortable
this is what we've talked about before
the one of the worst things about this
is that
it one of the things that frustrates me
so much and sickens me so much
is that
in
spreading this pronoun madness one of
the ways that the left's been able to do
it is by exploiting
in other people what are
good traits like people are like they
like they try to people most people like
to be polite they most people want
others around them to be comfortable
and these are in most situations that's
a positive trait
it's the advantage that i have is that i
don't share that positive trait so i
don't care about being polite
and i also really don't care if
you're
comfortable or not like it's that's just
it's not my
it's i don't live my life worrying about
that as far as i'm concerned it's up to
you to make stuff comfortable i don't
how's that my concern
so that's always been my approach and
that's why i've always been
less susceptible to this
but other people are are nicer and so
they they are
can be easily exploited
you know we talk so much about how
cowardice has led to the proliferation
of gender ideology and cowardice is a
big part of it
but i'm also willing to accept that for
you know a certain number of people
who initially went around along with the
pronoun stuff wasn't so much cowardice
as just they they just were trying to be
nice
and they probably didn't think about it
that much and
but then how quickly do they take
advantage of your niceness
um
and turn it into this
which is why i know it doesn't come
naturally to a lot of people and again
it's probably good if it doesn't come
naturally to you but we in order to
survive in this culture
and also to
retain and fight for
any semblance of sanity and moral
decency you're gonna everyone needs to
have a little bit of a harder edge
and you gotta get used to saying to
people
who who tell you that what would make
them comfortable what would make them
happy you have to get used to saying to
them i don't care that's your problem
no ill will
you know go off and try to be
comfortable and happy
but it's not my concern
all right a little bit more from this uh
segment with the
hr she's an hr expert i don't know if
she actually works works in hr
this is like i thought the worst thing
possible is to work in hr but she's
found one level that's even worse to be
you don't work in hr you're just you're
an hr expert outside of hr um you are
the hr for hr
we'll watch a little bit more of this
also if as you're learning to address an
individual by a pronoun you can always
just use their first name can't go wrong
with their first name right so
colton
is over there right right colton will be
here soon so you don't have to use a
pronoun at all if you're not you know
familiar with it if it feels unnatural
what if someone is refusing to use
someone's preferred pronouns and this
will happen i will be very honest in the
workplace this will happen we have
feelings about the pronoun we don't
agree with it so we don't know why we
have to use it
so it's important if you don't agree
to still just use their first name
this isn't something that would rise to
the occasion of getting written up if
you refuse to use it but this could rise
to the occasion of bullying that person
may be repeatedly asking you
this is how i would like to be referred
so it
it wouldn't rise to the occasion of
getting written up but it but it would
be bullying and then bullying gets
written up so ultimately you're still
going to get written up i do want to
clarify one thing because this is
important she says that
she allows
right she's willing to she has grace
enough to admit that um
there will be people who refuse to use
the pronouns if you can believe it dear
god there are people out there who
refuse to use them and and because they
have feelings they have feelings about
your pronouns
and uh and they have their own feelings
and their own opinions about it and
they're against it
well i want to clarify one thing is as
one of the people who will absolutely
refuse to use your pronoun
it's not so much that i have feelings
about your pronoun i actually i cause
i'm not thinking about your pronouns at
all so it's hard i don't i don't
generate any feelings about them because
i'm not thinking about them
okay um i don't have enough
it's to say i have an opinion about i
don't have an opinion either about it
it's not an opinion like if you're a man
then you're a he that's not an opinion
it's just a fact
as far as feelings aren't a lot of
feelings about it i don't go go around
have thinking about what's their pronoun
oh this is how i feel about that i just
don't i just don't care see so you
are coming to me
you're the one with the feelings you're
the one who cares and you are coming to
me and
and asking me to do something
and so it's not up to me to justify
myself it's not up to me to have
feelings about it to explain my quote
opinion or anything like that
i have lived my whole life calling men
he women she and and because that's what
you do and that's just and that's that's
how i've lived my life
you're coming to me with a request and
which is really a demand
telling telling me to change telling
telling me what you want me to do so
it's up to you to explain why i should
the burden is on you
give me one good reason
so as always they say they're trying to
flip it around
where we have to justify ourselves
if we want to continue simply living in
reality where men and our men and women
are women then we have to justify
ourselves
but it doesn't work that way i don't
have to justify anything you have to
justify
so if you're a man coming to me saying
oh i need you to call me call me a she
why should i do that
now i'm listening i'm sitting i'm
standing right here in front of me i'm
not going to run away screaming
if you have a really great argument
if you have something you could present
that would make me abandon everything i
know about reality and the rules of
grammar then i'm all ears go ahead and
tell me
but all you have is well make me feel
better okay
it would make me feel better to abandon
reality so
and we're talking about what i'm doing
here not what you're doing so why would
i do that
i know you're craving some more matt
wall show content well i have some great
news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com and subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast i'll see you there